estamos con el gobernador de la
Administración militar de jarquín olek
cine
Muchas gracias por esta entrevista
gobernador
jarquín ha sufrido muchos ataques nos
puede contar un poco la situación de los
de la destrucción Cuántos edificios han
sido afectados las infraestructuras que
en este momento hay afectados en toda la
región
el monto definitivo de daños aún no se
ha calculado pero son cientos de miles
de millones de dólares porque han sido
dañados o destruidos más de 18.000
objetivos de los cuales más de 10.000
Son estructuras residenciales
casas privadas casi 300 hospitales
alrededor de 800 centros educativos y
aún no hemos liberado todo el territorio
de la región de harkids
hay daños en cientos de kilómetros de
carreteras Y esta es nuestra
infraestructura crítica la que genera
electricidad de la calefacción
también se ha visto afectado el sector
agrícola con la destrucción de
maquinaria agrícola y Campos Estas son
las pérdidas que sufren cada día
nuestros empresarios
Cuántas personas
se han ido de la región de jarquín y
cuántos desplazados internos hay
en este momento Hay 460.000 personas en
la región de hard y la ciudad de arquid
que tienen la condición de desplazados
internos
que viven en el territorio de la región
de abandonaron sus edificios porque
actualmente es peligroso para estar allí
y algunas personas viven fuera de la
región y alude
Cuántos Cuántas ciudades Cuántas aldeas
están a un bajo ocupación rusa y cuál es
la
en estas ciudades en estas aldeas
hay unos 29 asentamientos bajo la
ocupación temporal del enemigo alrededor
de 3 asentamientos están en la llamada
zona gris
la situación allí es extremadamente
difícil es prácticamente imposible vivir
allí casi todas las personas se han ido
pero los que permanecen allí no tienen
suministro de Electricidad agua gas no
hay instalaciones de atención médica por
lo que la situación allí es
extremadamente difícil
no tenemos acceso a estos territorios y
durante la agresión a gran escala de la
federación rusa no hubo ni un solo
corredor humanitario ni un corredor de
evacuación que permita o saque personas
de allí o entregue una carga humanitaria
allí aprovechamos las oportunidades que
tuvimos teniendo en cuenta la situación
militar las personas que entregaron
ayuda o evacuaron personas en realidad
arriesgaron sus vidas
se cumple un año de la guerra en Ucrania
esta ciudad ha estado bajo asedio luego
ha continuado a sufrir más ataques se
espera
más presión de parte de la tropa rusa se
espera que vuelvan a atacar a jarquín
de forma significativa
por supuesto la presión sobre la región
de nunca ha parado Aunque ahora el
enemigo no tiene la capacidad de llegar
con sus sistemas de misiles de cohetes
múltiples por lo que no tenemos una
situación tan difícil
estábamos en una situación como la
ciudad de gersón en ese momento el
enemigo incluso disparó contra las
paradas de transporte público los
civiles y tuvimos esa situación Hasta
que liberamos el territorio y empujamos
al enemigo hacia las fronteras por
supuesto entendemos que el enemigo no ha
abandonado la idea de la ciudad de
arquive los territorios perdidos en
otoño en el territorio de la región de
jarquín construimos fortificaciones las
24 horas del día y ayudamos a nuestras
fuerzas armadas hacerlo más efectivas
posibles en el campo de batalla Cuál es
la situación de los de las ciudades y
los pueblos retomados como
es estable se espera ahí también
temen ahí también que haya más ataques
que las tropas rusas intenten retomar
esas zonas liberadas en septiembre
en este momento la situación allí es
completamente estable el suministro de
Electricidad el suministro de agua y el
suministro de calor sean restablecido
por completo en la medida de lo posible
porque algunas casas han sido destruidas
se han restaurado seis salas de calderas
de 23 porque las otras están
completamente construidas
en cuanto a otras áreas pobladas que han
sido liberadas la situación allí es la
misma y en cuanto a aquellas áreas donde
no hay suministro eléctrico tenemos 13
mil situaciones de este tipo pero esto
depende de los trabajos de desminado y
reconstrucción
llega suficiente ayuda humanitaria a
harquive que Qué cantidad de población
necesita en este momento comida
medicinas nos puede dar también una
cifra para entender cuál es la situación
humanitaria de la región
Quiero agradecer a todos nuestros socios
internacionales incluidos los que han
enviado las miles de toneladas de ayuda
humanitaria que recibimos y seguimos
recibiendo
hemos creado sedes de coordinación para
que podamos podemos distribuir y enviar
ayuda de manera más efectiva a donde más
se necesita de hecho el año pasado
entregamos más de 65.000 toneladas de
ayuda humanitaria entre alimentos
medicinas y productos de higiene y a
nuestros distintos territorios
comentarnos
y productos nuestra tarea principal
ahora es volver a poner en marcha la
atención médica en los territorios
desocupados prácticamente
por ejemplo en la ciudad de donde el
hospital quedó completamente destruido
allí hay un plan para reconstruir esta
instalación hay fondos internacionales
que están listos y otro proyecto
actualmente se está trabajando en esa
dirección
[Música]
Ucrania entra hoy en el segundo año de
guerra que se espera para la primavera
por supuesto estamos esperando nuestra
Victoria actualmente tenemos una
escalada en la dirección de cupián en el
norte es decir el enemigo ha aumentado
el número de bombardeos de nuestros
asentamientos en esa zona sin embargo
creemos en nuestras fuerzas armadas y
todos estamos trabajando por nuestra
Victoria común como señaló nuestro
presidente el evento principal que
esperamos en 2023 es nuestra Victoria